yeah Steven Shu is Hong Kong's top
political influencer on YouTube he has
close to 700,000 subscribers and direct
up to five videos a day videos often
criticized their Chinese leadership that
could technically fall afoul of
Beijing's new national security law for
inciting hatred against China for people
that are making noises in the web like
me it is very dangerous and I have been
on the watch list for for a long time
now with this flag the ultimate fear you
said you would not have the protection
of law you can arrest me and put me in
jail even the former Hong Kong system
are not afraid but in the Chinese system
it is different
it got so dangerous the shoe moved to
Taipei at the beginning of the year at
the age of 70 but he never thought he
would be away long term then Beijing
passed the stringent security law he now
likely faces arrest if he returns to
Hong Kong very difficult very said I
don't expect that when I came to Taiwan
that I cannot go back 70 years of my
life I'd ever let go for but the maximum
period is check these up days yeah now I
have to leave Hong Kong forever it
breaks my heart the law climbs down on
protests and freedom of speech at least
a dozen people have already been
arrested since I talked effect on the
first of July many of them were simply
carrying a Hong Kong independence flag
taiwan has strongly supported the
anti-government protest in Hong Kong
since they broke out last year and like
show thousands of Hong Kong people are
applying to move to Taiwan the
government even recently set up an
exchange office to help those with
humanitarian needs Taiwan is walking a
fine line in struts relations with
Beijing reflecting the sensitivity of
the matter no one from the government
granted us an interview for the same
reason most of the Hong Kong is here are
also reluctant to talk to the media
those who have already sat out here
struggle to find a sense of belonging in
Taiwan where the culture and language
are different
Stephen Chow opens this small
supermarket last month were his house
Hong Kong snacks and drinks it's more
than a store for him it's a community
where his fellow citizens can gather and
make friends
the feeling of Hong Kong people can only
be shared by Hong Kong people this is
change you know the breaking up of the
charity Stern of Hong Kong
is very difficult for people like me to
it just emotionally mutual help is very
important in these crises of life
meeting Connors and speaking Cantonese
it reminds me of home so I'm very happy
to be here it certainly has not been
easy to start a whole new life in a
foreign place but at least a Hong Kong
people have each other
and a taste of home for more let's bring
in the reporter who filed that for us in
Taipei Joyce league day - Joyce I want
to pick on pick up on something you
mentioned in your stand up there the
presence of dissidents like Stephen
Taiwan is is putting the government
there in Taipei in a very difficult
position regarding its powerful neighbor
China yes that's correct
with the increasing military threat from
Beijing the Taiwanese government is very
afraid that Taiwan would be the next
target of Beijing after Hong Kong so
what the Taiwanese government is doing
is that they are offering low-key
assistance to Hong Kongers so that that
won't trigger Beijing to a point that it
will escalate to a war or something you
know a college but also they could stand
with Hong Kong and provide assistance
okay now as Taipei moves forward with
this low-key as you called it policy
towards refugees coming from Hong Kong
is it nonetheless expecting more people
to be fleeing to its shores yes
certainly actually last last year when
the pro-democracy movement broke out
there was already over 5,000 Hong
Kongers clean to Taiwan you know
applying for a residence permit so this
trend will continue and the time.i
Taiwan government is expecting the
number to grow so a lot of Hong Kong
people here they may be
having difficulty adjusting to the new
environment and many of them are forming
Hong Kong communities or social groups
to support each other okay as they form
these support groups to support each
other what about the people in in Taipei
and in Taiwan more broadly are they
accepting the new arrivals umm Taiwanese
people are generally very sympathetic to
the Hong Kong people and they are
generally welcoming new immigrants from
Hong Kong but then there's also another
problem the practical problem like how
saying education medical resources so
the government the Taiwanese government
also have to tackle these practical
problems while standing with Hong
Kongers on the side of democracy a very
difficult situation for the government
in Taipei there
GWS Joyce Li reporting for us from the
capital of Taiwan thanks very much